une impression qui va devenir dévorante
un tourments amoureux natalia petrovna
is life la maîtresse de maison s'éprend
d'un jeune étudiant un mois la campagne
est l'oeuvre la plus célèbre d'yvon
tourguéniev une création censuré en 1850
c'est quand même très descriptif de
manhattan société russe dans les années
tout bénef a d'ailleurs écrit un essai
qui s'appelle un homme de trous le
journal d'un homme de troupe et c'est la
génération
déjà nous ont quand ils reviennent après
avoir fait leurs études à berlin
il comporte pour y associer tous très
traditionaliste
alain françon signe une mise en scène
subtile et délicate où l'interprétation
retenu des personnages masculins
contraste avec les mois féminin c'est
aussi une pièce qui fonctionne beaucoup
sur sur les émotions mais qui
effectivement jusqu'à jusqu'à flaubert
et tourgueniev je veux dire c'est
seulement l'élite qu'ils pouvaient avoir
des émotions les gens du pauvre était
jamais concerné par sa part les états
d'âme et justement dans ces pièces comme
dans les romans tourgueniev ou comme
chez flaubert ou comme sternthal tout à
coup je vais dire tout le monde a droit
une création au casting d'exception
menée par anouk grinberg les is life
vous invite à passer quelques jours en
leur compagnie
dt je n'ai jamais vu sur son visage
d'extraction pareil